dinamarca se convirtió en el primer país
en dejar de utilizar por completo la
vacuna de astrazéneca las autoridades
sanitarias del país tomaron la decisión
tras estudiar un posible vínculo entre
casos de coágulos sanguíneos y el uso
del fármaco en el mes que ha pasado
investigamos intensamente estas señales
con expertos nacionales e
internacionales
güi jaf en quien sufría ahora estamos
convencidos de la plausibilidad y la
causalidad de que este raro síndrome de
trombosis es muy grave sars y of the
sure también tenemos una estimación de
riesgo de un en 40.000 de los vacunados
este es un nuevo conocimiento que no
teníamos cuando pusimos la vacuna de
astrazéneca denuncia when we chuck
destrucción y que la decisión causará
retrasos en la vacunación del país a
partir del 25 de julio y hasta
principios de agosto la semana pasada la
unión europea informó haber detectado un
posible vínculo entre el uso de la
vacuna y casos de trombosis cerebrales
aunque indicó que la mortalidad por kobe
19 comporta un riesgo mayor que los
posibles efectos secundarios de la
vacuna
dinamarca indicó haber tomado la
decisión en función de su bueno
control de la pandemia y señaló que no
descarta su uso en el futuro en una
situación diferente no dudaría en
utilizar la vacuna de astrazéneca en
dinamarca / energy from situation but y
si otros países continúan con nuestra
técnica en función de su situación y
contexto específicos por supuesto lo
entenderé my world oshkosh andy stern
hasta el 4 de abril se habían detectado
169 casos de trombosis en europa tras la
administración de 34 millones de dosis
de la farmacéutica varios países
europeos ya han retomado la utilización
del fármaco muchos sin embargo lo
destinan a los mayores de 60 años al
considerar que éste conlleva riesgos
mucho menores para esta población que un
contagio por kobe 19